[Music]
now self-consciousness holds that object
to be good and possess intrinsic being
in which it finds itself and they have
to be bad in which it finds the opposite
of itself goodness is the likeness of
objective reality to it
badness however there unlike this at the
same time what for self-consciousness is
good and bad is intrinsically good and
bad for it is just that in which these
two moments of intrinsic being and a
being for it are the same it is the
actual spirit of the objective realities
and the judgment is the proof of its
power within them
a power which makes them into what they
are in themselves it is not how they are
like or unlike directly in themselves
that is not abstract being in itself or
being for itself that is their criterion
and their truth but how they are in the
relation of spirit to them their
likeness or unlike Ness to spirit
spirits relation to them in virtue of
which they lose their initial status of
objects and develop their own in itself
or intrinsic nature becomes at the same
time the reflection into themselves
through which they acquire the actual
spiritual being and what their spirit is
comes to view but just as their first
immediate determination is distinct from
the relation of spirit to them so also
will the third moment their own proper
spirit be distinct from the second first
of all their second in itself which
stems from the relation of spirit to
them must of course turn out to be
different from the immediate in itself
for this mediation of spirit rather acts
on the immediate determinant Ness and
makes it into something else
I think that paragraph 496 can be quite
a difficult transition point in part
because Hegel here is talking about all
of these in itself and you know first
one a second one what is he actually
getting at there he's using these these
categories that I think by this point in
the phenomenology were pretty familiar
with but he's differentiating them
against each other and a lot of this is
is quite abstract so let's see if we can
unpack this a bit and and make some good
sense of it a lot of it will you know
fall into place as we move into the
paragraphs yet to come so he says that
self-consciousness is at this point is
going to differentiate between the good
and the bad we've already seen that
taking place the gute and shellacked
right and he says that it's it's holding
that object to be good and to possess
intrinsic being that is to exist on Zeek
in itself in which it finds itself so
self-consciousness finds itself in some
object and remember the objects that
we're talking about here are wealth on
the one hand and state power on the
other not something else like you know
the project of painting a house or you
know doing one's taxes or anything like
that we're talking about these two
fundamental polarities within the
ethical substance so he goes on and he
says it finds the that to be bad in
which it finds the opposite of itself in
which it finds a lack of equivalence so
it finds something like itself to be
good and it finds something unlike
itself to be bad and so the same thing
could be good or bad depending on how it
is that self-consciousness is orienting
itself to it how self-consciousness is
perceiving it and this could be another
self-consciousness this can be you know
state power or its representatives
wealth or its representatives or
one's experience of it in any case
what's going on here is the bad is being
identified with unlike Ness and this is
going to be happening throughout this
section
so he says goodness is the likeness of
objective reality to it and here Hegel
you know uses gag and Stanley can
reality attached right he doesn't he
doesn't speak in terms of veer clea kite
which we might translate as reality or
actuality either he talks in terms of
something being an object right gig and
an Lika presenting itself as an object
as a reality so goodness is the likeness
the gleich height the you know gleich I
- you could you could say likeness works
quite well the equation the the ad
equation you know something which is
adding up to through this this likeness
adding up showing us that that it really
is the thing right and then he says
badness is there unlike Ness wouldn't go
like height now is that the end of the
story no because he goes on and he says
what for self-consciousness is good and
bad is intrinsically on Zeke good and
bad for it is just that in which these
two moments of intrinsic being and of
being for it are the same so there's a
kind of abstraction going on here and we
know whatever we're dealing with
abstraction in terms of Hegel's
phenomenology we we're not really
finished with what it is that we're
attempting to do we want to get to the
concrete so what we've got here is what
we could call an abstract in itself and
for itself the the good is that which is
in itself it possesses intrinsic being
but it does so at least at first at this
point for self consciousness in an
abstract way and the bad likewise is
just being set up as its opposite here
so he says it's the actual spirit of the
objective realities
the and the judgment is the proof of its
power within them a power which makes
them into what they are in themselves so
here we have an interesting way of using
this notion of in itself typically in
the Hegelian dialectic the in itself has
been construed as that which sort of
unfolds itself that which is already
there right that which is in a certain
sense not for itself that which is not
conscious of itself which is not taking
a position in relation to itself but
that which is just you know just there
it is just is all right here hiegel is
talking about spirit making the things
that are in themselves be in themselves
does that mean that spirit is just
postulating them there know it what it
means is that to be in itself is in a
certain sense to be made to be in itself
to be brought out as what it is that
sounds rather abstract as well but but I
think he'll forgive that abstraction for
a moment so he says it is it isn't how
they are like or unlike directly in
themselves not abstract being in itself
for being for itself that is their
criterion and their truth now notice
he's not saying that they don't have
abstract being in itself or being for
itself he's just saying that's not here
going to be their criterion and their
truth and remember truth is something
that for the Hegel dialectic Hegel's
dialectic he has to be developed has to
be unfolded right it's not something
that we we take as a certainty of this
height right off the bat but something
that we earn and that is what spirit is
doing in this this process so what else
can we say about this he goes on and he
says it's their likeness or unlike this
to spirit right that matters how they
are in the relation of spirit to them
spirits connection its relation it
engagement with them he says is what
gives what allows them to lose their
initial status of being just objects for
self-consciousness and to develop their
own in itself their own intrinsic nature
there are on Zeke Heights we might say
all right the what it is that they are
so goodness and badness aren't at the
beginning entirely what goodness and
badness our spirit has to work upon them
and show us what genuine goodness
genuine badness actually are by making
them into something more than just mere
objects for spirit giving them a kind of
agency this is something we're going to
see unfolding a little bit later in what
we can call not just in wealth and say
power but the noble and base
consciousness so he goes on and he says
this is what gives them an actual
spiritual being and that that way what
their spirit is comes to view and then
Hegel says well look for we had a first
immediate determination and that's
distinct from the relation of spirit to
them and then we have a third moment
where what we're talking about is their
own proper moment as good and bad now as
spirit sort of apportioned off to each
of them he says this is going to be
distinct from the second he says there's
second in itself which stems from the
relations of spirit to them must turn
out to be different from the immediate
in itself now isn't that an interesting
thing to say in itself is usually taken
to mean something that is self same
right something that remains the same
over time something that we can rely
upon but here Hegel is saying even for
the the good which is supposed to be in
a sort of self same relation to itself
to self consciousness to spirit there's
a there's a slippage there is a movement
from the first in itself to the second
in itself so the even the in itself has
some disparity within itself so he says
this turns out to be quite different and
he talks about this in terms of the me
radiation of spirit acting on the
immediate determinate 'no sand making it
into something else
so even in the self-same there is an
other in taking place
it follows them at the consciousness
that is in and for itself does find in
the state power at simple essence and
subsistence in general but not its
individuality as such it does find there
its intrinsic being but not what it
explicitly is for itself rather it finds
that the state power dist owns action
qua individual action and subdues it
into obedience the individual therefore
faced with this power reflects himself
into himself it is for him an oppressor
in the band for instead of being of like
nature to himself its nature is
essentially different from that of
individuality well on the other hand is
the good it leads to the general
enjoyment is there to be made use of and
procures for everyone the consciousness
of his particular self it is implicitly
universal beneficence if it refuses a
particular benefit and does not choose
to satisfy every need this is accidental
and does not detract from its universal
and necessary nature of imparting itself
to all and being a universal provider
here in paragraph 497 we're going to see
the very first of the major reversals
involved in these judgments about good
and bad and and what they're objects are
take place and something similar is
happening here to what we saw happen
just earlier in the spirit section in
terms of the divine law the human law
the individual human being that oriented
him or herself in relation to it here of
course our polarities are wealth and
state power and up until this point
Hegel's either has been talking about
just the good and the bad themselves in
terms of likeness and unlike Nisour he
has been talking about wealth as being
the bad and state power as being the
good now we see the first of these
shifts in which somehow the good becomes
bad and the bad becomes good in this
case it's going to be state power that
turns out to be bad somehow now how does
that happen
notice that that one of the things Hegel
is not going to do is to totally you
know change everything and say that
state power isn't you know the essence
the vases or the translating here the
subsistence the be stayin of the human
being of the individual but he is going
to change the meaning of these for the
individual and and it's important to
remember here the stress that Hegel is
laying upon judgment upon you know
another way of translating judgment here
there's you know that's that's got a
technical sense to it right where we
bring something under a concept and all
that but another way of thinking about
judgment that's a little bit older and
more old-fashioned is to think about it
in terms of opinion or in terms of
standpoint you know we can be wrong in
our judgments and and our judgments can
change over time so Hegel says that the
consciousness that is in and for itself
right the human being
that we're talking about in this case it
may not be all human beings at this
point in history that are in and for
themselves but at least somebody some
individual consciousness attempting to
orient itself thinking out you know what
is the good what is the bad in terms of
wealth and state power which are two
very important you know social forces we
might say or phenomena things that
present themselves to us he's going to
say that it does find in the state power
it's simple essence it's Vaes them right
it finds its essentiality what it is who
it is who who it matters to and it's
subsistence but it doesn't find
something else it doesn't find its
individuality there's no room for its
individuality within the scope of state
power now isn't that a strange thing why
couldn't it you know be an individual in
relation to state power stocks mocked
why can't it serve state power and
retain its individuality well oftentimes
you know state power in order to
exercise it properly or to serve it you
you will have to sacrifice things that
you would say are you know related to
you perhaps your family life right or
perhaps you know in times of war your
own life or the life of those members of
your family just think of you know some
of the great heroes in you know Rome or
you know in the Middle Ages oh and this
is really about these sorts of times so
they have those provide us with some
some examples you certainly do have to
sacrifice your own desires the objects
of your desires where perhaps your
happiness may lie at certain points in
order to satisfy the demands of state
power you also sacrifice your own
individual judgment in a way and perhaps
that's even more important here
so he says it finds a state power
disowns action quoi
individual action that is it subsumes
the individual action into its own the
individual action matters insofar as it
fits into the projects and the aims and
the values of what what constitutes
state power so you know for instance if
you're a judge you have a certain
function and so long as you're
performing that function while you have
some manner of discretion not only in
terms of how you decide cases but how
you run your courtroom and you know he
perhaps even how you you dress to a
certain extent all right but you can
only go so far with that it's it's it's
not you know whatever you deem to be fit
because if you do that you are setting
yourselves at odds with the the state
power and this would take place in a
variety of different ways right anybody
who's been in the military I don't I'm
sure there's something like this and the
other branches we used to say there's
the right way the wrong way and the army
way right and the Army in this case is
state power its way is the way that
we're gonna worry about right and wrong
that is for the army to decide not for
you as the individual to decide of
course you know in certain acts the
cases they want you to exercise
initiative but that is for the purpose
of the the greater whole isn't it so he
goes on and he says it disowns action
qua individual action and here's where
it where the the bad comes about it
subdues it into obedience so what it is
that the individual has to offer their
own unique perspective on things perhaps
their their own talents and skills and
propensity xand all of these things that
make them who they are their background
their their memories you know state
power is not interested in that state
power is is looking for somebody who can
fill the position do the job and then
shut up and go home and get ready to do
it the next day when state power wants
it done or pay
in the middle of the night you know go
on alert or something like that
so he says state power subdues the
individual into obedience so the
individual faced with his power he says
reflects himself into himself now that
could be as prosaic as having one of
these sort of flash moments where you're
like what the hell is going on here what
am I doing here I thought I was like
furthering democracy or being part of a
you know greater whole or becoming an
army of one you know if you think about
the old ads that we used to see all
right I thought I was doing something
meaningful but I'm just taking orders
and so the individual by being for
itself comes to a position where it
judges and doesn't just feel doesn't
just think doesn't just receive from the
outside but actively judges state power
to be something bad to be an oppressor
to be impeding it in its unfolding its
development in satisfying its desires so
state power is gone from being something
fundamentally good precisely because it
did provide the essence to being
something now bad so he says it becomes
an oppressor in the bed instead of being
of like nature to himself its nature is
essentially different from that of
individuality it's not an individual a
great example of this you know we have
this interesting legal fiction here in
the United States that was affirmed in a
very important legal case that the
Supreme Court heard a while back and had
to do with the notion that corporations
are persons and you could you know I
understand that you might say well the
corporation is on the side of wealth but
really insofar as a corporation behaves
in a sort of hierarchical manner
and has a chain of command and comes to
dominate an area think about these
massive multinational corporations whose
you know earnings are greater than the
GDP of many countries they actually are
functioning much more like a state power
aren't they and each of these these
corporations is something different than
a person you know we the the real upshot
of that of course had to do with
political discourse and not political
discourse as actual political discourse
but political discourse as shooting lots
of money into the heat the veins of the
the body politic right but you know
don't don't let that seduce you into
thinking that we're talking about wealth
here because we're really talking about
as a kind of power a kind of way of
dominating the system and siding for
entire swathes of people the way things
are going to go a corporation is
something fundamentally different than a
person a government even more so
and what does Hegel talking about here
you know the individual cannot deal with
state power or any organization as if it
were dealing with another individual the
the individual in a certain sense
doesn't matter in relation to state
power except in so far as the individual
fits into as I said the designs and
demands that state power imposes upon it
which are experienced as being bad and
oppressive what's being experienced is
bad and oppressive there is a
fundamental lack of recognition that the
state power is unable to provide
precisely because it is so fundamentally
different from the individual and
there's lots of interesting confusions
that take place here that we could chalk
up to kind of an ideology or you know
the workings of psychological dynamics
you know in in medieval times there was
this this tendency to identify the state
power with the the figurehead at the top
and to say you know well the king really
cares about me or the prince or the
count or whoever you like right
sometimes the bishop the abbot but you
know they really care about me as a an
individual person even though I'm very
lowly but you know the reason why the
state behaves like a jerk to me is
because the bad ministers you know if
the King really knew it was going on
he'd set this all right
and you know half the time it turns out
no the King doesn't know what's going on
and and it is signing off on it because
you know as representative of this state
power the king doesn't care about the
individuals except insofar as they they
fit into that scheme so what about
wealth then how does that fit in here
Hegel says that the individual you know
is going to now turn to looking at
wealth wealth becomes the good why is
wealth the good is it because we retreat
into if we can't have power we retreat
into a pecuniary interest and say you
know sour grapes those grapes over there
more tasty I'll pick some of them and
maybe trade some of them and we'll
circulate them around now Hegel is is
really attuned to what goes on within
economies wealth is never just the
wealth that is accumulated and sits in
somebody's storehouse or Treasury or
bank or under your mattress it's
something that allows exchange that
allows circulation that that gets
people's desires to align with each
other so Hegel says wealth is the good
it's judged as the good here why it
leads to the general enjoyment it
produces something that is general and
general in a different way than the
essentiality of the state is
a general enjoyment and enjoyment in
which each individual can have their
share this is idealistic of course right
in the sense that is that the way
economies really function no well quite
a few people are getting screwed at any
given time but there is you know the
fact that some people are actually
getting something out of it and so
there's this possibility of you know as
we say all boats floating to the top
right we're gonna build we're gonna job
growth or our way into Universal
happiness well
Hegel's talking about something like
that he says wealth is there to be made
use of that's another thing that's well
worth thinking about well if like I just
said isn't really wealth when it's just
being saved it's there to be made use of
it's there to be you know exchanged for
other kinds of wealth it's there
you know money is there to be exchanged
for property or services or even
promises about things that are going to
happen down the line sometimes we use
money to try to make more money too as
well alright or we convert money into
other money usually losing a little bit
in the process unless we were currency
traders in which we gain some of the
process and he says it procures for
everyone the consciousness of his
particular self isn't that an
interesting thing to say it procures for
everyone the consciousness of his
individual self so the the individual
person who was you know sort of as Hegel
was saying reflected in upon him or
herself is able through wealth through
the generation of wealth through the
spending of wealth through the
circulation of wealth to get to know who
and what he or she is you might say if
we want to be a little facetious here
and and you know play off of you know
little lines like you know you are what
you eat
we might say you are what you purchase
you are what you earn and that would be
in fact truthful
at least to a certain extent some people
are entirely consumeristic and that's
all they've got going for them right
others you might say there's there's
things elements dimensions that escape
that you know the economy but it is
quite important this isn't something
that we should just abstract away and
say doesn't matter at all
Hegel is aware of that economic things
really have a big impact upon ourselves
so he goes on and he says it is
implicitly wealth is implicitly
universal beneficence now notice he's
being more realistic in saying this if
it refuses a particular benefit and does
not choose to satisfy every need this is
accidental and does not detract from its
universal and necessary nature of
imparting itself to all and being a
universal provider he talks about wealth
here as being a universal provider
precisely because wealth stands for this
economic Nexus which draws all of these
individuals in has them work has them
exchange has them consume has the whole
process replicate itself this is turning
is sounded a lot like Marx isn't it at
this point there's a good reason because
Marx did in fact take quite a bit from
Hegel who knew about this he was not
unconscious of the the existence of an
economy within which he lived
you know Hegel had a job Hegel had to
have to buy things and provide for for
himself and for others so what is he
talking about here he says you know
implicitly this could provide benefits
to everybody
it doesn't actually provide benefits to
everybody but when we're looking at the
wealth side as the good what we're
ignoring and here's where Hegel and Marx
would actually depart from each other
what were what we're saying is that you
know it it's
not going to satisfy every need but
that's merely accidental that it doesn't
detract from this universal necessary
nature of providing something for
everybody and so what we get here is
something like a endorsement of the the
role of the markets and not called the
market as such understood more in terms
of the economy and wealth and of course
state power is going to be connected
with this in some way but notice how
stark the contrast that we've got here
is being set up and notice that we now
have the good on this side as wealth and
the bad on this side is state power with
the individual in the middle judging
both of them
you